-Finally, guys, it is Tuesday.
It's time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet"!
This is where we,
as a group, decide something
we should post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you
five different tweets,
and we're all gonna vote
on whether you
like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats?
I see people scrambling
for them, sharing them.
Everyone has their own,
so it's all gonna be fine.
You can vote for all of them,
you can vote for none of them,
whatever you want,
and we'll see the results live.
Higgins, you have your clicker?
-Got it.
-All right.
Your thumb's already on no.
-Well...
[ Laughter ]
Wanna be positive.
-Why --
-I wanna be positive.
-Yeah, but why --
-I'm gonna put "no"
on every one.
-What? You're gonna say no
to all of them?
-Yep, just so it'll be fair.
'Cause Tariq's --
Tariq's gonna go yes --
-Tariq, what are you thinking?
-I voted -- I'm done.
I voted "yes" to everything.
[ Laughter ]
-All right. Quest,
I know you're very positive.
You always vote yes.
-Always yes.
-Yes.
-I love my job.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out
live on the show,
so that you can all like it
and "wetweet" it.
-Nice.
-It's a shared experience.
You guys ready for this?
The first tweet is...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Some people laughing, some
people just stone-- stone-faced.
-Yeah.
-I don't know.
-Some people don't know they
should -- they shouldn't do --
-Yeah, I don't think
it's gonna work.
The votes are in.
Let's see the results.
-Oh, oh.
-All right, not bad.
Not bad. 100...
Very honest audience.
I like that, yeah.
-Lot of abstentions.
-Wasn't the -- yeah.
Wasn't the best,
wasn't the worst.
-Yeah. Wasn't worst.
Was fine.
-Let's see this next one here.
It says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Come on. That's true.
-That's rare.
-That's fair.
-That's a rare sighting.
-That's a rare baby name
nowadays.
-Yeah, it's like "What --
What's the name of your baby?"
"It's Cheryl."
-"Cheryl."
-Yeah.
-Gladys.
-All right, here we go.
You cast your votes.
Let's see the results.
-Oh!
-Oh, barely better.
♪♪
-"Cheryl" --
-I love that -- barely better.
We might not even
tweet one out tonight.
Who knows?
[ Laughter ]
Next one here says...
Oh, that's interesting.
[ Audience groans ]
That one got -- you can't --
you can't boo the jokes.
Just...
[ Laughter ]
...thumbs up or thumbs down.
Please no booing.
-'90s George Carlin.
-I don't need any
audible booing of jokes, yeah.
I don't even think
we need to wait.
Let's just see the results.
This is gonna be a landslide.
Yeah, okay.
[ Sad tuba ]
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
-Wow.
-Here we go.
This next one says...
-I'm gonna say
this one's gonna win.
-"It's not connecting,
it needs ink.
Uh, honey, do we need to make
any more CD-ROM labels?"
All right, here we go.
Let's see the results.
-Oh!
Squeaky, but very nice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
You're being very nice tonight.
-Wow.
-You're being a very giving
audience tonight.
I appreciate that.
We're down to our last one.
Here we go.
It says...
[ Laughter ]
Cast your vote.
This one...
I feel good -- I feel best
with this one.
I think.
I don't know.
All right.
I think everyone
cast their votes.
We know if it's
gonna win or not.
Let's see the results here.
Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
By far, by far!
Thank you!
-Whoa!
-That was, by far, the winner!
I'm gonna post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a "wetweet," and enjoy.